bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'ère de
par le manque d'eau pour cette nouvelle
saison avec cathy builder toujours
michael mojo katia et cette semaine dans
l'actualité marquée au parlement par
deux débat sans vote
l'un sur l'initiative de la france de
frapper la syrie par voie aérienne
le premier ministre a de nouveau vécu
toute présence au sol des militaires
français
l'autre débat de la semaine concerne
l'accueil des réfugiés sur le sol
français manuel valls annoncé que la
france n'hésiterait pas à rétablir
temporairement le contrôle à ses
frontières hasard du calendrier les
républicains tenait le même jour une
convention sur le thème de l'immigration
enfin le sénat a commencé à examiner le
projet de loi sauter un texte
profondément remanié par rapport à celui
examiné à l'assemblée
un exemple phare exit les paquets
neutres pour les cigarettes détail dans
quelques minutes
jean christophe lagarde est l'invité de
parlement hebdo bonjour bonjour le
président de l'union des démocrates et
indépendants député maire de drancy l on
a beaucoup beaucoup de questions à vous
poser sur l'actualité mais je vous
propose d'abord de voir ce petit
portrait de vous vu par quelques-uns de
vos collègues
regardez c'est vrai que reprendre lui
dit après le départ de jean louis borloo
s'était pas facile
et puis son élection a été compliquée du
délit c'est une somme de petits partis
et comme tous les présidents des petits
partis était candidat il a réussi à
gagner mais je pense
aujourd'hui sa voix et peut être
affaibli par le fait que ses concurrents
n'est pas totalement digéré leur défaite
donc je pense que l'exercice est un
petit peu difficile pour lui pour ces
raisons là c'est un homme de conviction
c'est énorme de combat il a démontré
dans son département
c'était un homme avec lequel il est
difficile de discuter souvent parce
qu'ils défendent plus d'inciter ses
positions mais c'est aussi un ami un
homme de dialogue avec lequel
personnellement je m'entends très bien
je pense que parfois c'est quelqu'un
d'un homme est seulement mesurer un peu
engoncé dans les accords avec les
républicains moi j'aimerais qu'il soit
parfois un peu plus courageux et qu'il
regarde un peu plus ce que fait la
majorité et et je l'invite véritablement
à séparer quand même de settat colmant
avec les républicains parce que j'ai la
ferme conviction qu'il ne partage pas
les mêmes valeurs sur un certain nombre
de sujets c'est un type pas mal avec
laquelle j'ai de bonnes relations
parfois paradoxales plein d'allant bon
orateur
je ne pense qu'une question qu'est ce
qui fait à lui dit vous faites à lever
c'est une vision que jacques myard peut
avoir du fait qu'être centriste n'est
pas avoir d une commune des convictions
mais d'être une espèce d'entre-deux de
synthèse et celle inverse
en tout cas pour moi celle inverse être
centriste être humaniste être
fédéraliste c'est pas une synthèse de ci
ou de ça c'est une ligne qu'on doit
suivre alors c'est vrai que pour
d'autres raisons
parfois la multiplication des chapelles
l'envi des parcours individuels des as
les autres grands parents parents pas
les choses très facilement avoir
suffisamment lisible mais on est en
train de les rendre lisibles et jacques
myard doit se rassurer bien mais nous
n'avons pas du tout la ligne politique
la même ligne politique
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il ya deux
parties c'est votre retrait ce week-end
la retrait de lui dit ça va être quoi le
signal audio vous devez vous aimerez
finition de ce nouvel élan pour la
rentrée lutter contre l'impuissance
publique
je trouve que sur cette rentrée ce qui
est le plus frappant c'est l'état lâche
quotidien de l'impuissance publique de
la parole vide qui donne la parole non
tenue
vous ciblez le gouvernement aux cellules
et à vos cibles et la droite je cible le
gouvernement et parfois je pense qu'à
droite on doit regarder ce qu'on a dit
et ce qu'on a fait c'est là c'est là les
deux pieds à l'heure à gauche et à
non c'est pas une question de pièces et
une question de conviction je pense que
l'impuissance publique est allée chaque
jour à la fois dans l'action
gouvernementale dans les discours
politiques
ça fait le lit de l'extrême droite et
qui évidemment délire sur tous les
thèmes possibles mais j'aime pour
flatter les instincts des français or ce
qu'attendent les français ce sont des
responsables politiques qui n'ait pas
peur de l'opinion publique et qui soit
capable de la changer en expliquant les
enjeux et vous vous avez dans
l'actualité récente on va y revenir à
redon vous avez dans l'actuelle
intéressante la démonstration de ça il
ya un mois on nous expliquait que les
français aient refusé catégoriquement je
crois à 80% refusé catégoriquement qu'il
puisse y avoir un accueil des réfugiés à
des pages non mais juste pour montrer
qu'on les responsables politiques quand
ils n'ont pas peur du peuple ils peuvent
changer les choses et il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui les français ont compris
qu'on devait accueillir ces gens là
qu'on n'aurait pas fermé la porte aux
juifs allemands entre 1933 et 1939 que
personne ne remettra dans des charters
les gens qui sont arrivés ici au péril
de leur vie pour les mettre dans les
mains de dice et égorgeurs revenir très
précisément un petit peu plus tard dans
l'émission va d'abord parlé de la santé
si vous voulez bien c'était lundi à
l'assemblée nationale mais après au
sénat
quinze jours d'examen pour les sénateurs
sur la loi bas-rhin de marisol touraine
qui a été profondément modifiée par
rapport à celle de la somme nationale
ont fait le point avec sophie normaux
ils avaient annoncé leur intention de
réécrire complètement le projet de loi
santé
les sénateurs de droite et du centre
majoritaire au palais du luxembourg
n'ont pas tardé à détricoter le projet
de marisol touraine
mardi le sénat décide ainsi de
l'interdiction à compter de 2017 des
cabines de bronzage à uv contre l'avis
du gouvernement le sénat remet en place
à l'intérieur du texte ce qui a été
écarté le par le gouvernement le même
jour et toujours contre l'avis du
gouvernement le sénat modifie la loi
evin qui encadre notamment la publicité
sur l'alcool les sénateurs défenseur de
la vigne tous élus de régions viticoles
veulent pouvoir promouvoir le patrimoine
culturel et gastronomique lié au vin
nouveau camouflet pour la ministre de la
santé dès le lendemain mercredi la mise
en place du paquet de cigarettes neutre
et supprimer les sénateurs dénoncent une
atteinte au droit des marques et préfère
s'en tenir à la directive européenne qui
prévoit un paquet couvert à 65% de
messages sanitaires
on se demande pourquoi vous déployer
autant de trésors pour certains d'entre
vous a essayé de contrer cette
initiative
marisol touraine s'y attendait un débat
dure et très clivée et d'ici au vote
solennel prévu le 6 octobre plus de 1100
amendements au total vont être discutés
mais le dernier mot reviendra à
l'assemblée nationale c'est la torah de
ladite beaucoup de déception par rapport
à tout ce qui a été fait par les
sénateurs je pense par exemple vous
pouvez dire ce que vous pensez du paquet
neutre terminé on remarque d'abord ont
pris en en préambule je crois que c'est
marie mitzel touraine qui a beaucoup
déçu le monde de la santé
ses certitudes cette espèce de rigidité
permanente sur tous les sujets qu'elle
aborde et y compris quand elle est dans
l'erreur
cette incapacité à écouter les autres
les médecins les professions de santé
aujourd'hui le parlement les sénateurs
c'est vraiment la marque de fabrique de
marisol touraine parfois d'ailleurs avec
une espèce de caractère hautain et
méprisant
moi je voudrais bien madame tauren il
n'est pas honteux de se tromper
ce qui est honteux c'est le persistez
vous pensez qu'elle s'est trompé sur
toute la préparation je pense qu'elle
l arrêter je pense qu'elle serait paquet
d'autres sur le tabac c'est sûr beaucoup
de choses et ensuite quand vous prenez
l'exemple d'un décor du tube du paquet
neutre
on est là encore dans comment dirais-je
l'anecdote le symbole ça sert à quoi
vous croyez vraiment quelqu'un qui fume
c'est parce que le paquet change de
couleur ou que il change une marque
qu'il arrête de fumer non on a besoin de
politiques publiques de prévention
on a besoin d'un certain nombre de
choses on est dans le gadget plutôt que
dans le fond experts la direction du
tiers payant pour à votre exode katia
parce qu'on en a aussi beaucoup parlé
c'est une erreur aussi grave erreur
grave erreur
et là encore mensonge en direction des
français aujourd'hui ceux qui ont des
difficultés en l'occurrence pour accéder
aux soins réellement ce sont les
français qui n'ont pas de mutuelle et
ceux qui n'ont pas de mutuelle ils ont
rien à fiche du père p du tiers payant
puisque toute façon le tiers-payant say
on pay la part de la sécurité sociale et
on avance quand vous êtes en train de
vous dire pardon une loi pour rien c'est
ce que vous avez c'est une loi qui se
trompe de cible
dans ma commune dans mon département les
gens qui ont des soucis d'accès à la
santé sont ceux qui n'ont pas de
mutuelle c'est pas le tiers payant leurs
problèmes
alors que ça facilite la vie certes
qu'on rembourse plus rapidement mais
très franchement avec la carte vitale
aujourd'hui on est remboursé quand on a
une mutuelle sous 72 heures en règle
générale donc ce n'était pas les
sensations de la droite comme des sommes
sur un peu contradictoire sachent quoi
je crois simplement que là encore on
touche l'illustration
on agite un colifichet sous le nez des
français pour dire voilà nous sommes des
grands réformateurs nous avons
transformé les choses et on laisse de
côté ceux qui avaient réellement besoin
en l'occurrence d'avoir un accès aux
soins
alors lundi toujours jean christophe
lagarde françois hollande était au
chevet des campagnes le chef de l'état a
co présidé un comité interministériel
sur la ruralité accompagné de onze
ministres c'est un sujet de marib remo
séance de calinothérapie pour l'exécutif
qui vient séduire les campagnes onze
ministres au tour de manuel valls et
françois hollande pour un conseil
interministériel au ruralité en haute
saône
parmi les annonces du chef de l'état le
détail du fond d'un
milliards d'euros débloqué en faveur des
collectivités locales une moitié
c'est-à-dire 500 millions d'euros
accompagnera les priorités définies
conjointement conjointement entre l'état
et les associations d'élus sur la
transition énergétique les
infrastructures le logement
l'autre moitié sera destinée au
territoire vaut une enveloppe
conséquente qui tombe à pic à trois mois
des élections régionales l'exécutif fait
les yeux doux à des territoires qui se
sentent souvent oublié et parmi les
vingt-et-une mesures en faveur de ces
territoires une était particulièrement
attendue françois hollande a ainsi
annoncé que 700 médecins généralistes
seraient formés à l'aide médicale
d'urgence d'ici 2017
l'objectif qu'aucun habitant ne soit
plus de 30 minutes d'un service
d'urgences l'installation des médecins
en milieu rural sera aussi favorisés
mais pas sûr que cela suffise à calmer
la grogne des maires ruraux inquiets de
la réforme territoriale et de la baisse
des dotations à voile alors justement ce
sera ma première question ça cette
baisse des notations qui suscite une
fronde très importante chez chez vous et
lui vous vous vous allez être dans le
cortège ce samedi dans l'impression
quand même que c'est un coup politique
c'est pas le cas non je ne crois pas là
encore on à l'illustration de
l'incapacité d'un pouvoir à écouter à
dialoguer et quand on écoute pas et
qu'on dialogue pas on ne peut pas mener
des coups politiques publiques de long
terme
il ya deux erreurs dans cette affaire
bien sûr qu'il faut que les
collectivités locales participent à
l'effort d'économie nationale parce que
tout simplement on dépense plus haut
niveau de l'état d'abord au niveau des
collectivités locales également que ce
que nous gagnons que ce que nous
produisons comme richesse chaque aile et
les rares alors alors l'erreur elle est
à la fois sur le ciblage et sur la
rapidité à laquelle on demande la
décroissance des dépenses pourquoi parce
que quand vous demandez à une mairie un
département une région de réduire ses
dépenses peut pas réduire le
remboursement de ses emprunts
il peut pas réduire par dont la charge
de son personnel qu'est ce qui réduit
les investissements et vous au moment au
moment où nous recherchons de la
croissance ont réduit les
investissements et ont fait ça deuxième
chose au moment où le gouvernement en
place à boules
versez toutes les collectivités locales
par la métropolisation c'est la loi
d'autres parlent les nouvelles régions
par l'affaiblissement des conseils
départementaux
cette panne économique là qui menace le
secteur du bâtiment et des travaux
publics est une erreur parce qu'en même
temps entre guillemets qu'on réduit
l'investissement ont réduit la capacité
de ce week-end alors des mères à redon
c'est quoi ce grand rendez-vous des
mères ce grand rendez-vous les mères
c'est pour dire toutes sensibilités
politiques confondues
il ya des maires de droite de gauche du
centre dans un littéraire et qui veulent
simplement dire bien sûr nous pouvons
participer à la réduction du déficit
public mais à un rythme qui soit
raisonnable et responsable vous savez
moi ces responsables avaient dans la rue
dallée les avis est allé le rechercher
je vous invite l attendait un élu quand
on est inverse c'est raisonnable d'aller
dans la rue quand on n'est pas entendu
pas un gouvernement qui est sourd et
aveugle aux conséquences de ce qu'il
fait moi j'ai rencontré à l'époque avec
une délégation de l'ue dit le président
de la république nous lui avions déjà
dit attention la rapidité à laquelle
vous demander cet effort ne tiendra pas
il ya des 'colombes' la rue pardon il ya
des cantons n'avait plus d'autre moyen
de vous faire entendre
évidemment quand vous demandez quand
t'as quand vous regardez le nombre de
communes qui sont quasiment en
banqueroute en faillite
quand vous regardez l'augmentation
d'impôts que les élus sont obligés de
poser il ya d'ailleurs un comportement
très lâche de la part du gouvernement il
dit je ne vous augmente plus les impôts
je voulais réduit et il transfère en
réalité la responsabilité de le faire
dans les collectivités et vous
rechercherez si ça vous intéresse en
2011 à l'assemblée nationale je disais
moi en l'occurrence dans une
intervention qu'il fallait que nous
puissions de baisser les dotations de 2%
par an sur une dizaine d'années pour
revenir un rythme à n'importe quel élu
s'est retrouvé 2% dans son budget mais
quand vous demandez 11 milliards d'un
coup sûr 70 milliards ça ne peut pas
tenir ça va craquer et c'est pour ça que
les accords passés au mardi
il ya un grand débat l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat sur les frappes au
sol
c'est tout un débat à l'assemblée et au
sénat mais sans vote la france veut
frapper aux scieries les français le
premier ministre a de nouveau exclu
toute forme d'intervention terrestre une
écoute un passage entre le premier
ministre et christian jacob c'est le
président des républicains l'assemblée
nationale des frappes seront nécessaires
et nous choisirons seuls les objectifs à
frapper mais bien sûr il est hors de
question que par ses frappes
nous contribuerons à renforcer le régime
de bachar al assad
nous ne changeons pas de stratégie nous
ne changeons pas de cible nous luttons
contre le terrorisme oui à une
intervention en syrie mais à plusieurs
conditions
d'abord avec une résolution du conseil
de sécurité de l'onu les frappe
exclusivement aérienne tous les
militaires le dise
risque de n'être qu'un coup d'épée dans
l'eau jean christophe lagarde est ce que
pour vous le cadre d'intervention de la
france en syrie et éclaire alain voc
pour cela l'article
la légitime défense c'est à dire
l'article 51 de la charte d assure julie
elle a raison de le faire c'est de la
légitime défense ou et au delà de
l'argutie juridique quel ridicule on
entend le premier ministre dire ne
changeons pas de stratégie mais de qui
se moque t'on il y a deux ans et demi ou
trois ans le président de la république
voulait bombarder bachar al assad et les
forces syriennes
si on l'avait fait à l'époque moi je me
suis élevé contre sale qui serait au
pouvoir aujourd'hui en syrie déj
les barbares de neige sur la totalité et
pas des gens qui ne nous font pas la
guerre des gens qui nous font la guerre
pardon premier acte deuxième acte le
président de la république invente une
nouvelle stratégie
il ya un an et demi deux ans de cela on
va bombarder d'âge parce que c'est
effectivement dangereux et ce sont des
barbares qui sont en train de perpétrer
un génocide que ce sont des gens qui
préparent des attaques contre nous mais
on va le faire à moitié on va le faire
en irak est temps qu'ils sont en syrie
ont leur démission pour que pour une
intervention total aux annonceurs pardon
il faut quand même un peu de mémoire
dans la vie publique pour comprendre
qu'on veut clair au 6ème jour pour une
intervention quant aux cantons changent
sans arrêt de stratégie on peut pas y
arriver alors je disais d'ailleurs à
l'époque quand on fait la guerre à la
moitié à 50% on s'assure l'avait fait à
100% et aujourd'hui vous dis prend le
prétexte pardon on prend le prétexte de
d'attentats qui ont lieu au mois de
janvier pour réaliser début de septembre
qui doit bombe a bombardé la syrie c'est
ridicule
l'absence de stratégie de la france dans
cette affaire me consterne je vous le
dis comme je le pense
alors ensuite oui je les dis je les
écris il ya quelques jours dans un grand
quotidien du soir
il faut pas dire aux français qu'il n'y
aura pas d'intervention au sol jeu sur
jacob a raison tous les militaires tous
les spécialistes expliquent et c'est
bien normal que des frappes aériennes ne
permettent pas de régler une situation
telle que celle là
pardon de le dire depuis deux ans non
pas qu'il ya six avions français qui
vont bombarder la syrie qu'est-ce que ça
va changer à y être
depuis deux ans il ya 4000 frappes
aériennes et des chats progresser en
irak et en syrie
donc soit nous arrivons à constituer une
coalition derrière les pays de la région
d'abord appuyé par l'iran appuyée par la
russie appuyés par l'otan au moins
l'europe et si on n'y arrive pas est-ce
qu'il faut des troupes au sol française
et combien cette coalition elle
nécessite des troupes au sol pour
retirer adech les villes qu'ils
détiennent aujourd'hui qui leur
permettent d'avoir des ressources
financières des ressources pétrolières
des ressources logistiques des repères
d'où il a dix ans tout leur sens à
grande-anse elle rit parce que c'est
très bon gars se trouvent surtout en
séries mais vous croyez franchement tu
les terroristes ils sont juste sentir y
est pas en irak
ils sont dans l'est alors très
franchement si monsieur hollande parce
que là c'est se moquer du monde va vous
lui si monsieur hollande pense que
depuis deux ans
c'est en syrie est pas en irak et qui
m'ont barre des qu'en dira qu il vaut
mieux immédiatement qui quitte ses
fonctions
il faut bombarder massivement pas les
bombarder massivement avec tous les
dégâts collatéraux ne servira pas à me
connaître la gravité le départ des
bâtiments je pense que c'est ce n'est
pas la bonne stratégie une erreur je
crois qu'il faut que les pays du golfe
d'une part appuyé par la russie par
l'otan épargnants et je vais vous qu'on
se trompe quoi et je les enviais
hollande nicolas sarkozy je vous donne
rendez-vous dans 12 mois 18 mois et 24
mois il va falloir qu'on attende encore
des attentats du type world trade center
pour se dire que nous avons besoin de
nous défendre
il faut que je ne cesse de répéter ça
depuis le mois de janvier ces gens-là
nous font la guerre et nous ne le
faisons pas alors on peut renoncer à
faire la guerre mais ça ne nous évitera
pas les attaques les agressions et sa
n'évitera pas la barbarie aujourd'hui on
cumule trois dangers majeurs
le premier c'est la vague migratoire
auquel on assiste le second sur les
attentats auxquels nous nous exposons
et le troisième c'est la déstabilisation
de la jordanie du liban de l'ensemble de
la région qui accueille des millions de
réfugiés alors un moment donné comme je
le disais tout à l'heure les
responsables politiques leur boulot
c'est pas d'attendre que l'opinion
publique réalise c'est d'expliquer les
enjeux en l'occurrence les dangers et le
fait qu'il va falloir prendre de
responsabilités la question à la légère
on va y venir à y aller seul regard mais
je répète une coalition des états de la
région elle est en train de se
constituer sous l'égide de vladimir
poutine et nous avons c'est la dernière
chose que je voulais pas dès qu'il
faudra donc parler la régie alors on
tourne a ajouté évidemment c'est une
évidence depuis le début qu'elle détient
bacha la russie ce qui à bachar al assad
non elle soutient le parti baas qui est
là et on a vu il ya deux trois jours que
la russie était prête à se débarrasser
de la charrette des salles enfin bachar
al assad qui est un effroyable dictateur
excusez moi pour l'instant il n'a pas
attaqué ni la france ni les pays
occidentaux
c'est pas le cas de brèche alors je
propose qu'on sélectionne nos
adversaires et nos enjeux et d'abord
pour ce qui nous concerne dans notre
défense et pardon je voulais absolument
dire ça il y a un enjeu européen majeur
dans cette affaire les etats unis sont
en pleine campagne électorale et donc il
n'y aura pas d'intervention ou de
soutiens américains massifs
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que c'est
de la responsabilité de l'union
européenne et de la russie que de
trouver cette coalition est de régler ce
problème qui est à nos portes et qui
entre guillemets on va être extrêmement
dangereux pour nous on va en parler
d'abord on passe à mardi l'actualité
c'est le budget michel sapin qui a
présenté les grandes lignes du projet de
loi pour 2016 c'est un sujet d'elsa mon
magasin deux semaines avant une
présentation plus précise du budget le
ministre des finances en a dessiné les
grandes orientations et il adresse tout
d'abord au gouvernement un satisfecit
les recettes rentre très bien il est
clair que nous tiendrons nos engagements
du printemps sur les finances publiques
nous avons également tenu le cap
vis-à-vis des entreprises pour ce budget
2016 il a fallu prendre en compte les
mesures de juin dernier en faveur des
tpe des pme elle reste dans l' enveloppe
globale du pacte de responsabilité mais
ont pour conséquence de reporter les
allègements de cotisations sociales pour
les salaires entre 1,5 et 3,6 me qu ils
interviendront le 1er avril 2016 et non
le 1er janvier comme initialement prévu
michel sapin a dû par ailleurs trouvé
comment financer les 2 milliards d'euros
de baisses d'impôts promises par
françois hollande
de sa conférence de presse de piste les
taux d'intérêt très faibles et la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale
nous avons mis en place à la fin de 2013
un dispositif qui permet à des gens qui
avaient de l'argent caché en suisse ou
au luxembourg ou à saga pour devenir de
déclarer leur argent de payer les impôts
qu'il doit cette année ce service de
traitement de régularisation va
rapporter plus de 2 milliards 6 l'année
prochaine nous avions prévu une somme
plus faibles ces deux milliards 6 aussi
des randonnées vous savez peut-être se
ralentit pas du tout pour les frondeurs
le budget 2016 est encore trop favorable
aux entreprises
j'espère que nos collègues du parti
socialiste le premier secrétaire les
députés ont poussé aussi avec nous pour
obtenir une réorientation de cette
politique pour alors une politique plus
juste plus efficace plus conforme aussi
est ce qu'on attend de la gauche le
projet de loi de finances sera présenté
en conseil des ministres le 30 septembre
puis viendra celui du financement de la
sécurité sociale
le 7 octobre prochain est ce que pour
vous ce budget ce projet de budget est
conforme notamment aux exigences de
l'union européenne puisque désormais on
est obligé d'avoir à une coordination
dans l'est dans les budgets
en apparence oui d'abord on n'est pas
obligé c'est pas l'union européenne qui
l'exigent
c'est que si effectivement vous êtes
irresponsables budgétairement c'est vos
créanciers qui vous prêtent plus
d'argent
on dit toujours que c'est la faute de
l'europe la réalité c'est la faute de la
politique française qui dépensent depuis
34 ans beaucoup plus d'argent que de
richesse que nous créons deuxième chose
c'est le dernier budget qui sera élaboré
et géré par françois hollande
trois ans et demi après on est encore
dans l'improvisation est ce que je peux
vous en donner trois exemples très
rapide vous en avez donné un dans le
comment dirais-je temps de reportage
françois hollande dit cet été je veux
redonner confiance je ne veux pas qu'on
change de règles fiscales tous les a
tous les instants le cic est adopté il
ya deux ans devait permettre aux
entreprises de voir une nouvelle baisse
des charges au 1er janvier c'est au 1er
avril
c'est un milliard d'euros de différence
vous croyez que ça ne change rien dans
les entreprises qui préparaient leur
budget premier exemple
deuxième exemple en octobre 2014 le
président de la république explique
qu'il veut une assiette plus large plus
juste
la redevance télé il explique qu'il faut
regarder du côté du numérique septembre
2015 rentrée conférence de presse il
explique que c'est une mauvaise idée
bravo monsieur le président vous avez
pris le temps de réfléchir mais il
faudrait pas changé la donne
est-ce que je peux un exemple comment
dirais-je vous donner un dernier exemple
il explique cet été au mois d'août qu'il
va baisser les impôts si la croissance
est là bon alors les chiffres arrivent
0% de croissance au deuxième trimestre à
la fin de l'été on nous explique que
c'est totalement afin qu'il y aura une
baisse de croissance qu'elle d'une
baisse d'impôts quelle que soit la
croissance au milieu de l'été c'était 7
millions de personnes à la fin de l'été
sans lumière
vous avez démontré qu'il y en a marre
lui dire quoi il y en a marre de
l'improvisation trois ans et demi après
on devrait avoir un gouvernement qui n'a
provisoire qui a une ligne et un cap
il est ballotté par les événements et
c'est sans doute ce qui rend le plus
inefficace les politiques publiques
parce que quand vous ne savez pas ce qui
va se passer et que vous êtes une
entreprise ou que vous êtes un
particulier quand vous êtes un
particulier vous ne consommez pas quand
vous êtes une entreprise vous
n'investissez pas que ce que vous diriez
pour les entreprises que pour aller au
tout petit peu plus loin 62 peut-être
envie d'être un petit peu plus à se
faire quoi qu'il aurait menti
françois hollande se connaître
entreprises sur le séisme bah écoutez il
a évidemment menti puisque gilles leur
promettait un rythme qui était calé
depuis deux ans il disait cet été que ce
qu'ils ne changeraient pas et il a
changé à la rentrée et a le droit de
changer très franc il a bien sûr le
droit de changer
il a même le droit de mentir les
français s'ils sont beaucoup habitués
alors mercredi on en a parlé déjà la
question des réfugiés est à l'ordre du
jour à l'assemblée
manuel valls a défendu la position de la
france discours de fermeté il n'exclut
pas un retour temporaire des contrôles
aux frontières on écoute
nous avons déjà rétabli ce printemps des
contrôles temporaires à cette frontière
et nous n'hésiterons pas à le faire de
nouveau comme les règles de schengen le
permettent à chaque fois que les
circonstances l'imposent
si c'est nécessaire dans les prochains
jours ou dans les prochaines semaines
est ce que pour vous jean christophe
lagarde il est nécessaire de rétablir
des contrôles au moins provisoirement en
france pendant cinq ans n'est pas
nécessaire les contrôles aux frontières
ça peut être efficace en période par
exemple de terrorisme ou d'événements
gravissime de sécurité excusez moi dans
ces cas là c'était au mois de janvier
est pas au mois de septembre qu'il
fallait rétablir ont envisagé deux
autres attaques d'ardon puis je je je je
trouve surtout entre lee mais dans cette
affaire que là encore où on s'agite
pardon de le dire aux le pen ou aux
autres qui suivent la même idée quand il
y avait des contrôles aux frontières
il y avait des clandestins dans notre
pays il y avait beaucoup de clandestins
dans notre pays quand françois
mitterrand arrivent au pouvoir ils
régularisent des centaines de milliers
de clandestins
on avait des douaniers à l'époque ce ne
sont jamais les douaniers qui ont
empêché les clandestins et d'ailleurs
ont fait fantasmer les français sur le
risque d'afflux massif de réfugiés qui
veulent venir en france
vous n'avez pas observé quelque chose
des réfugiés ils veulent aller où ils
veulent aller en allemagne
ils veulent aller dans les pays du nord
ils veulent aller en grande bretagne ils
demandent pas à venir en france parce
que la france même pour les plus
miséreux du monde des plus attractives
quand on nous vend en permanence que ces
gens veulent venir pour notre système
social
et bien non ils ne viennent pas ils ne
viennent pas je ne dis pas que les
français entassons plaindre mais c'est
bien parce que notre pays a un problème
enfin je pense moi que c'est l'honneur
de la france d'accueillir 7 et ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui victimes d'un génocide
que comme je le disais tout à l'heure
personne n'aurait compris ou accepter
qu'on refuse les juifs allemands époque
que personne ne renverra des gens
ils sont passés par miracle à travers la
méditerranée et ont survécu et qui vont
se retrouver ici et qu'on verrait entre
la main des égorgeurs ça n'existe pas
alors au lieu de vendre du vent là
encore une fois il faut expliquer aux
français que ces personnes là doivent
effectivement venir sur le territoire
européen qu'on doit les répartir alors
comment il faut des centres d'édifices
d'identification il n'y a pas que des
réfugiés qui ont droit c'est ce que je
vais aussi des migrants c'est ce que je
vais aller s'identifie nous c'est très
facile vous savez madame quand quelqu'un
vient d'afrique noire il parle rarement
l'irakien et le syrien
c'est assez rare donc c'est assez facile
à identifier deux je prends cet exemple
là mais c'est exactement le cas d'autres
pays
évidemment qu'il faut descendre
d'identification il faut rendre
efficient nôtre comment dirais-je notre
capacité à renvoyer chez eux les gens
qui sont venus clandestinement et qui ne
sont pas des réfugiés victimes du
génocide que j'évoquais pour ça de notre
point de vue il faut un ministère
européen de l'immigration qui aurait
trois missions la première mission c'est
de recueillir les besoins que les états
ont sur notre continent en main d'oeuvre
étrangère parce que la réalité que c'est
que l'allemagne elle va avoir besoin de
centaines de milliers de personnes parce
qu'elle n'a pas assez de jeunes pour
faire tourner son économie
la deuxième c'est que donc on confierait
à ce ministère la gestion de nos
frontières extérieures personne
aujourd'hui n'a de politique commune sur
la frontière extérieure ya pas de casque
parce qu'il n'y a pas de progrès dans ce
domaine là chacun voit religieusement
plutôt que de vendre le retour du
contrôle aux frontières
essayons de nous organiser pour qu'on
ait un progrès une prévision de ce dont
ont besoin les pays européens la
délivrance des visas et la capacité de
surveillance de nos frontières
harmoniser coordonné par ce ministère la
faire en sorte qu'on est d'ailleurs le
même la même politique de droit d'asile
et la même efficacité est ce que vous
savez qu'en france pour examiner la
demande d'un demandeur d'asile
on prend aujourd'hui entre 18 et 24 mois
que ça prend une dizaine de jours aux
pays-bas et doit que les premiers
parcours est hôtesse harmoniser vers le
haut et troisième mission de confier à
ce ministère la politique de coopération
de co développement avec les pays parce
qu'un des plus gros problème que nous
avons avec les clandestins ou les faux
demandeurs d'asile d'ailleurs c'est que
non seulement on met trop longtemps et
examiner leur dossier mais on ne
parvient pas à les renvoyer dans leur
pays parce que les pays d'origine les
refusent
eh bien nous devons absolument
conditionner le les aides au
développement que nous accordons à ces
pays au fait qu'il soit coopératif pour
réadmettre leurs lots
je disais ça il ya six mois tout le
monde est en train d'y venir j'en suis
ravi maintenant il faut se retrousser
les manches et effectivement de mettre
en avant ce christophe je parlais de
monsieur juncker à l'époque en disant
monsieur juncker ferait bien au lieu de
seulement faire les quotas de dire que
la politique européenne elle doit être
conditionné vis-à-vis de ces pays là
avec leur coopération contre la lutte
pour la lutte contre l'immigration alors
je reste of agathe coïncidence ou pas le
calendrier les républicains avaient
groupes thématiques pour une convention
organisée au siège c'était l'immigration
oui c'est bien nous raconte tout seul
s'ils disent oui ce sera littéralement
un plébiscite pour nicolas sarkozy
douze questions chocs sont posées aux
adhérents des républicains douze
questions qui reprennent pour beaucoup
les idées du chef du parti sur
l'immigration
elles portent entre autres sur la
suspension immédiate de l'espace
schengen et un rétablissement temporaire
des frontières sur la diminution du
regroupement familial ou encore sur une
évolution du droit du sol une inflexion
très droitière de l'ancien président de
la république
une façon pour lui de tacler ses
adversaires dans la perspective les
primaires du parti
quand j'ai voulu organiser cette journée
j'ai été immédiatement accusé de
droitiser de suivre jones et qui par la
gauche est normale mais même par une
partie des montres de fait lors de la
conférence de presse sur les bancs il
n'y a que des fidèles sarkozystes
absents revanche les rivaux françois
fillon alain juppé et bruno le maire le
parti aujourd'hui
ce résultat l'organisation des primaires
au parti c'est aussi un parti qui
réfléchit un parti qui intègre un parti
qui est unie avec ces questions
l'objectif du président des républicains
est clair il veut montrer qu'il est sur
la même longueur d'onde que la base
militante du parti quitte à lorgner sur
les voix du front national même si ses
lieutenants s'en défendent
le front national a rien à voir là
dedans on va pas s'amuser à cause de la
maladresse de la gauche à se faire
piquer toutes les régions parce que
madame le pen chaque jour engrange les
militants peuvent voter sur internet
jusqu'à vendredi soir 18 heures le
bureau politique du parti se réunira la
semaine prochaine pour valider ou non
leur choix et dans ce débat on a vu
surgir une question qui a l'air comme ça
une question de sémantique mais
finalement qui est une vraie question de
débat une vraie question de choix est-ce
qu'il faut demander notamment migrants
de s'intégrer ou de s'assimiler à la
société française s'est pas joué sur les
mots parce que visiblement chez les
républicains là dessus et à vrai débat
je pense que c'est totalement jouer sur
les mots et que de toute façon
s'intégrer dans la société française
c'est lorsque s'assimiler jean
christophe lagarde le pré l'explication
par écrit les neuf wagons vous le rend
si vous le permettez pas ce qu'est ce
qu'on demande à quelqu'un qui réussit le
territoire de respecter nos lois nos
valeurs de connaître notre histoire de
les accepter on ne lui demande pas
d'effacer ce qui l'a été ce d'où il
vient
est ce qu'on a demandé ça aux espagnols
aux polonais aux italiens à pourquoi il
serait pas ils sont toujours quelle ils
sont aujourd'hui d'excellents citoyens
français leurs enfants le sont aussi il
n'oublie pas pour autant d'où ils
viennent et je veux aussi parler des
maghrébins qui sont les postiers cette
question comptez vous lui poserez la
question parce que moi je suis pas
commentateurs de nicolas verreault
tomber dans ce qu'il dit là dans ce
qu'il dit là il ya plusieurs choses
moi je dis depuis longtemps et parfois
contre ma famille politique qu'il faut
réécrire schengen parce que ce texte à
25 ans ne correspond plus aux anglais de
l'accord avec l'ue n'est pas non pas sur
la façon dont ils veulent réécrire
moi je souhaite que n'aurait écrivions
schengen parce que la difficulté est la
suivante quand vous donnez un visa dans
l'espace schengen vous pouvez ensuite
vous installez l'étranger qui vient de
l'extérieur peut s'installer dans
n'importe quel pays
or l'allemagne je le disais va avoir
besoin de centaines de milliers de
personnes
et si en l'occurrence cette personne qui
était mise en allemagne va ensuite en
italie en espagne en belgique ou en
france on n'a pas besoin d'elle c'est
absurde
donc je suis pour qu'on ait la liberté
et de circulation mais pas
d'installation c'est un travail pour les
personnes et c'est ça qu'il faut
réécrire urgentissime mans dans schengen
nous serons totalement opposées
totalement opposé à une remise en cause
du droit du sol le droit du sol c'est la
république et le remettre en cause ce
n'est pas républicain
je le dis comme je le pense parce que on
ne peut pas considérer que des gens qui
sont nés sur notre sol qui sont allés
dans les écoles de la république qui
deviennent en réalité français à leur
majorité se verrait remettre en cause en
fonction du statut de leurs parents au
moment de leur naissance d'opposer
épilation si tu sais je vous ai fait
remarquer qu'il y avait deux parties je
disais à propos de jacques myard il ya
aussi des valeurs différentes sur un
certain nombre de sujets quand même
c'est une valeur absolument à quel rang
nous sommes totalement opposés à cette
idée mais je crois qu'au sein des
républicains il ya des gens qui
partageaient les barbus qui sont en fait
une famille politique vous rendez vous
et on a besoin de revoir le droit du
regroupement familial
en réalité d'ailleurs l'essentiel de
l'immigration en france on parle
beaucoup de l'immigration économique
dans un rapport récent ont montré que
les migrations économiques s'étaient
17000 personnes dedans il ya les
médecins qu on ne forme pas dans notre
pays mais il ya aussi un certain nombre
de métiers que les français ne veulent
plus faire
pardon de vous dire que vous regardez
qui aujourd'hui travaillent dans le
bâtiment pour garder aujourd'hui qui
travaille pour ramasser vos ordures etc
donc c'est pas vrai qu'on est un drap
l'immigration économique marginal 17000
personnes vous rendez compte de quoi on
parle en revanche il ya 90 mille
personnes environ qui arrivent chaque
année par le regroupement familial et là
il ya des questions à se poser
parce qu'en réalité une partie de cette
population
comment dirais-je ne vient pas pour
travailler simplement pour accompagner
et là effectivement je pense qu'on
devrait et j'ai dit la semaine dernière
que dans le cadre des réfugiés qui sont
eux dans l'urgence en vie victimes de ce
génocide en danger de mort on devrait
privilégier ces gens là par rapport au
regroupement familial qui est plus un
élément de confort je quitte de seconde
cette question des réfugiés parler
puisqu'on parlait des républiques
j'avais peut-être vu là une de
quotidiens du vendredi que cette fois le
figaro magazine avec françois fillon le
parisien avec la brd honorable on va
dire de nicolas sarkozy qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous président d'un parti
lui dei qui se rapproche quand même des
républicains
je crois je ne vois pas l'utilité de
refaire l'histoire du mat du quinquennat
précédent
non je pense que les français sont en
train de regarder le rétroviseur et
qu'ils sont désespérés de voir notre
pays ne pas être capable de se projeter
vers l'avant de quasiment si on en croit
à la fois les observateurs et les
sondeurs de reproduire en 2010 est la
présidentielle de 2012
on refait le match c'est bien quand on
quand on parle de football ou de rugby
puisque bientôt sous la coupe du monde
mais très franchement nous sommes la
seule démocratie française à ne pas être
capable de se renouveler à tel point
qu'on pourrait refaire le même match de
la présidentielle avec les cinq pubs
d'acteur vous y croyez pas je crois que
c'est surtout un des éléments qui
exaspère les français alors on va se
recentrer sur les sujets régaliens si
vous voulez bien avec la décision du
président de la république de ne pas
livrer les bâtiments de projection et de
commandement mistral à moscou
cette décision a donc été soumise au
parlement c'était jeudi
ce jeudi les députés ont donc été
consultés sur cette décision de la
france la france qui a déjà versé
l'argent à la russie qui espère
maintenant trouver un autre acquéreur
auditionné par les députés laurent
fabius se dit confiant écouter
l'accord obtenu dans ces circonstances
pareilles total nago satisfaisant le
montant définitif sera probablement ma
dicton de l'ordre de 1 milliard cent
millions comme la france a récupéré la
pleine propriété des navires l'objectif
d'indiquer c'est de les revendre
rapidement et à un bon prix
ce qui diminuera d'autant le coût final
pour l'état est ce que pour vous cette
décision porte atteinte aux intérêts
stratégiques de la france dans la mesure
où côté français comme côté russe
finalement on était quand même assez
pressée de se visiblement de se
débarrasser de ce dossier non je pense
d'abord que la décision du président
public était la bonne on ne vivront pas
les mistral au moment où il l'a fait en
pleine crise ukrainienne il fallait
marquer un coup d'arrêt à ce que
vladimir poutine était en train de faire
dans ce pays
je pense que le règlement financier est
très correct en réalité on va devoir
payer ce qu'on a décidé il n'y a pas
d'excès dans la matière le vrai sujet
maintenant ses acquis et à combien on va
revendre parce que le coût final ce ne
sera pas un milliard cent si on vend à
moitié prix on aura quand même 150
millions de coûts dans cette affaire ce
qui n'est pas agréable je pense
globalement que ce dossier a été
correctement géré par le gouvernement
gérera ses autres partenaires
j'aime ce qu'elle pouvait faire du
journal le figaro haut niveau c'est la
loupe du score bonjour jean christophe
lagarde joue lui déjà fait sa rentrée un
peu en ordre dispersé le parti radical
s'est rassemblée puis de nouveau centre
yves jégo va rassembler ses proches
ce week-end en seine-et-marne yves jégo
d'ailleurs il a pris tout le monde de
vitesse un peu au centre le week-end
dernier dans le jdd
en annonçant son soutien à bruno le
maire dans le cadre de la primaire la
droite et du centre
et ce alors que lui délit doit encore
bas a annoncé sa position sur l
éventuelle participation appelé à ce
sera en 2016
yves jégo c'est votre numéro 2 est le
numéro un du parti
il vous déborde un peu de sur le côté ça
ça vous agace
vous avez l'impression que chez les
bordés à ben moi non non j'ai dit non il
vous a pris de gégé dit pomme
vous croyez sur une course de vitesse
moi je pense que c'est une course de
fond et de fond pas sur la longueur de
fond de ce qu'on a à défendre et moi je
souhaite que lui dit puisse porter son
message devant les français alors j'ai
dit pendant que nous étions en campagne
interne pour la présidence de l'ue dit
et je n'ai jamais changé d'avis que nous
devions porter ce message est que nous
déciderions au printemps 2016
de qui le porterait et sous quelles
formes certains disent au sein du délit
c'est trop tard il faut se prononcer dès
maintenant les mêmes qui disent ça les
mêmes qui disent est en campagne
régionale disque finalement faut laisser
la primaire de côté ce que je trouve
hallucinant et franchement déraisonnable
pas que de la part de responsabilité de
l'ensemble
de la droite et du centre c'est que
cette rentrée on est donc en septembre
on se croirait en septembre 2016 la
présidentielle c'est dans 18 mois
dans cent jours il ya des élections
régionales et nous fédéralisme nous
croyons aux élections régionales j'ai
parce que c'est de là qu'on va pouvoir
redémarrer des territoires français
parce qu'ils ont la compétence
économique n'empêche dans informations
sur est de la compétence des de
l'aménagement du territoire et donc se
précipiter dans une élection
présidentielle qui a lieu dans 18 mois
et déraisonnable moi je suis un type
raisonnable mais déterminé je dis
simplement dans cent jours il ya une
élection qui est importante
ce concentrons nous sur celle là de
janvier à mars au sein de ma famille
politique on va discuter à la fois de ce
que nous voulons défendre de qui devra
le défendre et sous quelle forme et y
restera un an avant la présidentielle
vous avez l'impression que c'est pas
suffisant et vous croyez que je suis
débordée permet aux déborde
je vais vous citer quelques propositions
vous allez me dire très simplement par
oui ou par non si vous êtes d'accord
avec ces citations il faut emprisonner
les individus fichés est-ce donc pour
leur lien connu avec l'islam radical
est ce que vous êtes d'accord ou pas
d'accord évidemment non on ne peut pas
présumer la culpabilité de quelqu'un il
faut expulser du territoire les migrants
qui s'introduisent dans le tunnel sous
la manche wind ont rejoint l'angleterre
oui ou non je pense en tout cas qu'il
faut les sanctionner parce qu'on ne peut
pas avoir un comportement aussi
dangereux et dans l'espace n'a pas
d'expulsion puisque le oui non est une
simplification politique je dirai juste
d'un mot que ceux qui sont sur les
fichiers c'est qu'ils sont étrangers je
suis d'accord pour qu'on les expulse
d'accord je ne veux pas je ne peux pas
accueillir de migrants dans ma vie car
je n'en ai pas la capacité
d'accord pas d'accord oui il faut
regarder en fonctions réellement des
difficultés de chaque ville toutes ces
propositions toutes ces citations elles
viennent d'un homme sa vie de xavier
bertrand avec lequel lui dit et alliés
dans le nord pas de calais picardie
on voit qu'il ya parfois certaines
divergences idéologiques entre lui dit
les républicains pourtant vous atelier
est ce que ça pose pas un problème de
dos un souci stratégique bien évidemment
des différences je le répète sinon il
n'y aurait qu'un seul parti politique
mais pour gouverner il faut des
coalitions et il se trouve que c'est
vrai au niveau local et que c'est vrai
au niveau national et je pense même
d'ailleurs que nous aurions intérêt à
voir les coalitions les plus larges
possibles parce qu'un des grands drames
de la france c'est de changer de
politique tous les cinq ans c'est à dire
que quand vous voulez régler les
problèmes de fiscalité qu'on abordait
tout à l'heure
des problèmes d'éducation nationale sur
lesquels nous ne sommes pas venus de
transformation du territoire vous avez
besoin de consensus long une majorité
qui arrivent au lendemain d'une élection
présidentielle n'a pas de plus grande
priorité que de défaire ce qui vient
donc une action concertée dans sa pose
est donc au l'on se rend impuissant dès
lors qu'ils valent équilibres politiques
dès lors qu'il ya un équilibre politique
qui se constitue à la fois dans les
projets et dans les représentations des
listes ça veut dire en réalité qui aura
un grand changement
jusqu'à présent du temps de l'ump il
avait la majorité sans nous donc ce que
nous disions ne comptons pas vous ils
n'auront plus la majorité sans nous juge
dans les régions en question
ça veut dire vous allez dire que les
projets sur dives à radio miser sur 7
sur cette alliance sur ces régionales
que vous annoncez comme réussie pour
vous refaire au niveau du parti danse
comme réussissez des français parce que
filon parce que le apparemment udi à
quelques problèmes financiers c'est
libération qui le dit en tout cas dans
un
dans un article et un dirigeant
centriste qu'on cite pas qui dit jeudi
quasiment au bord de la cessation de
paiement est ce que c'est vrai c'est
absolument faux lui dit n'a aucun
problème de dépenses le bigoudi au
contraire dépensent moins encore que
l'an dernier elle a un problème de
recettes parce que l'une de ses
composantes qui elle est en grave
difficulté financière et qu'elle va sa
cotisation le nouveau centre et nous
sommes en train de travailler avec hervé
morin et avec d'autres pour pouvoir
arranger entre guillemets les
difficultés qui sont les leurs et du
coup donner plus de force à notre
mouvement
merci beaucoup merci jean auzemery rugby
par eh oui notre journaliste était avec
le quinze parlementaires les cas ce
qu'il regarde et alexandre darmon
nous sommes donc à richmond dans la
banlieue de londres où les
parlementaires de sept pays s'affrontent
pour leur coupe du monde de rugby
dan harmon et parlementaires français
disputent leur dernier match de la
compétition aujourd'hui face aux
all-blacks
ce que vous n'êtes voir c'est le haka le
chant traditionnel chanté par les maoris
avant de partir à la guerre et le font
avant tout les matchs de rugby et
souvent il sert à faire peur aux
adversaires alors est-ce que ça a marché
avec les français alors non c'est un
saint c'est impressionnant à voir mais
ça fait ça fait pas peur mais on a
l'habitude de le voir faut pas se
laisser impressionner parce que sur le
terrain ils sont 15
on est quinze ans et que le meilleur
gagne pour moi c'est la quatrième fois
que je joue contre eux et on sera
toujours aussi à l'empereur le regarde
dans les yeux et après c'est à nous
c'est un homme
ils ont deux bras deux jambes comme nous
c'est différent c'est un peu plus grands
bourreaux rendez vous dans quatre ans
pour la prochaine coupe du monde de
rugby au japon avec ou sans les all
blacks en tout cas jean christophe
lagarde
ils vous attendent alors vous y serez
faudrait que je m'entraîne un peu parce
que ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas joué
au près 39 0 les français ils
s'abreuvent qu'ils ont une grande marge
de progression mais ça je devais faire
un choix je préfère que mes collègues et
perdu 39 0 et que le quinze de france
remporté la coupe du monde
allez on verra ça merci beaucoup je
christine lagarde merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine très bonne si de programme sur
la chaîne de parlementaires merci de
votre fidélité